Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 20. In der letzten Woche gab es viel Chaosradio zu hören und es gab von euch eine ganze Menge Feedback. Das kommt heute dran und im zweiten Teil ein Gespräch über Macintosh Security am Mikrofon Tim Pritlove. Ja, willkommen zurück bei Chaosradio Express. Ich hab's schon erwähnt, eine Menge Feedback und angefangen hat es mit der Musik. Wolfgang schreibt, warum ich denn immer nur Zerinnerung spiele. Was hier glaube ich das Missverständnis war, ist, dass es sich bei Zerinnerung weder um ein Netlabel handelt, noch um eine Gruppe, sondern das ist im Prinzip nur eine Auswahl von DJ-Mixen, sprich jedes Mal gibt es hier einen anderen DJ zu hören, der dann aus einer anderen Bandbreite von Musik, Genres usw. auswählt. Von daher ist das hier eine schöne Ressource, aber ich bin trotzdem für andere Hinweise immer zu haben und spiele das dann auch gerne mal an. Aber so sehr viel Zeit, selber Musik auszusuchen, habe ich hier nicht, denn ich versuche mich hier ein bisschen auf den Inhalt zu konzentrieren. Ja, eine ganze Menge Feedback gab es. Unter anderem zu der Ausgabe Nummer 18 zum Thema Dropping Knowledge. Da hatten wir ja auch schon ein bisschen Feedback. Mittlerweile gibt es dort wohl auch einen Blog. Allerdings noch ohne RSS. Da muss also am Verständnis des Internets wohl noch ein bisschen gearbeitet werden. Ja, der Hinweis kam übrigens von Nils per E-Mail und per E-Mail gab es auch eine ganze Masse an Feedback zum Thema Phon, was ja das Thema war vom Chaosradio Express Nummer 19, das Interview mit Martin Wasowski und es kam zwar viel Feedback aber es war eigentlich immer die gleiche Frage und das kreiste um die juristische Situation habe ich zum Beispiel Mail bekommen von von Clemens, der darauf hinweist, dass man ja quasi als ISP auftritt und damit eben auch dem Loggen von Verbindungen drei Monate lang, also der ja Speicherung der Verbindungsdaten sozusagen nachkommen müsste und dass man halt im Zweifelsfall wenn jemand über den eigenen Anschluss was macht, ja in der Beweispflicht ist, wenn Unfug getrieben wird, was immer Unfug auch immer sein mag. Ein ähnliches Horn stößt Sebastian, der halt einfach schon mal fragt, ob es überhaupt Erfahrungsberichte mit Providern gibt und er ist Versatel-Kunde, hat mal durch die AGBs durchgeschaut und Punkt 5.1, eins in dem Vertrag, verbietet ihm schlicht und ergreifend, dass er dritten Internet anbieten darf, was er von Versatel bezieht. Und soweit ich weiß, gibt es auch eine ganze Menge andere Proviser, die ähnliche Richtlinien haben. Matthias schreibt wiederum, mir ist dieser Service bereits im November 05 aufgefallen, ich würde gerne als Bilder am Netzwerk teilnehmen. Was mir zu kurz kam, waren halt die juristischen Fragen, weil der Martin eben vielleicht auch nicht der richtige Ansprechpartner ist. Das ist er ganz sicherlich nicht, weil er sich eben im Detail auch nicht damit beschäftigt. Es gibt jetzt einen Beauftragten hier auch für Deutschland. Ich hatte jetzt leider nicht die Zeit, da noch mal Fragen zu formulieren, E-Mail-Verkehr zu machen, weil hier einfach derzeit eine ganze Menge los ist. Und dieser Podcast hängt auch schon viel zu lange in der Luft. Aber ich habe mir grundsätzlich noch mal ein bisschen das Thema durch den Kopf gehen lassen. Und es gibt natürlich einige Fragen, die hier noch beantwortet werden müssen. Und jetzt, wo ich sie nicht beantworten kann, kann sie vielleicht aber auch jemand anders beantworten. Also zunächst einmal muss man sich klar machen, dass dieser Fondienst das Login für einen übernimmt. Sprich, man stellt zwar sein Internet bereit über diesen WLAN-Router, aber der Login-Service, also die Software, die auf der Firmware von dem Router läuft, prüft quasi gegen die Datenbank von vorn. Nur dort sind die Benutzer eingetragen. Sprich, dort findet eben eine zentrale Speicherung der ganzen damit bezogenen Personendaten statt. Schon mal die Frage, wer ist denn da jetzt überhaupt zuständig, weil das Ganze befindet sich dann im Zweifelsfall eben auch nicht in Deutschland. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die das planen, ob die ein verteiltes System haben werden, ob das alles in den USA liegt oder auch in Spanien. Das ist schon mal eine gute Frage. Und man kann sich halt auch nur über dieses Login-System einloggen. Ich habe jetzt die Software selber noch nicht getestet, da würden mich auch Erfahrungsberichte von euch mal interessieren, insbesondere wie das eben für einen selbst ist. Wenn man jetzt quasi seine eigene Leitung nutzen möchte über WLAN, muss man sich dann auch einloggen. Heißt das, dass ich quasi auch für die Nutzung meiner eigenen Leitung auch Verbindungsprofile dort erzeuge. Das sind alles solche Fragen. Es gibt halt zwei Software, die da zum Einsatz kommen. Das eine ist OpenWRT, das andere ist das DDWRT. Den Namen kann man schon ansehen, dass es in Dresden entwickelt ist. Während das OpenWRT einen relativ offenen Entwicklungsprozess hat, ist das bei dem DDWRT derzeit noch so eine One-Man-Show. Es gibt auch noch kein öffentliches Subversion-Archiv, also noch keine offizielle Möglichkeit an dem Entwicklungsprozess an solchen Live teilzunehmen bzw. es zumindest live zu verfolgen. Das ist aber in Planung, also dort soll auch der Source Code demnächst in ein Subversion-Archiv marschieren. Ja, also diese juristische Geschichte und natürlich auch, wie das grundsätzlich ist, wenn man als ISP gilt, das ist hier noch die große Frage. Ich habe auch noch so ein bisschen meine Bedenken. Die Software sieht natürlich auch zahlreiche Sperrungsmöglichkeiten vor, kann halt Protokoll sperren, sprich man kann halt von vornherein sagen, ich will nicht, dass jetzt hier Vittorrent läuft und ich möchte bestimmte Keywörter nicht haben oder ich möchte bestimmte URLs nicht haben. Dann stellt sich mir natürlich die Frage als Kunde oder auch als Teilnehmer des Netzes, was bedeutet das für mich? Das heißt, ich verlasse mich jetzt sozusagen auf diesen Service-Zahle, für den auch noch Geld. Aber dann habe ich so, je nachdem Goodwill des jeweiligen Betreibers, kann ich halt diesen Dienst nicht nutzen oder dieses Protokoll nicht benutzen. Das erscheint mir dann doch noch ein bisschen unklar. Also hier fehlen die Qualitätsmaßstäbe, die an die Betreiber dieser Phone-Spots gestellt werden, irgendwie vollständig. Na ja, auf der Webseite gibt es auch noch ein bisschen Probleme. Ich habe mal versucht, mich da zu registrieren. Da kann man sich aber irgendwie nur mit Tricks durch dieses Formular durcharbeiten, weil die Buttons dann irgendwie von vorne nach hinten wieder durchspringen. Und es ist auch noch eine Frage, inwieweit das Projekt kryptografische Verfahren einzusetzen gedenkt, inwieweit man halt also die Möglichkeit hat, dort verhältnismäßig sicher den Zugriff zu nutzen. Das nächste Mal ist es natürlich alles unverschlüsselt, außerdem Login, der halt über HTTPS läuft. Gut, das überrascht mich zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch noch nicht. Es ist ja ein relativ neues Projekt und das hat auf jeden Fall auch noch seine Chance, sich zu beweisen. Wenn ihr Erfahrungen damit gesammelt habt, dann würde ich mich an der Stelle über Feedback freuen und dann bau ich das auch gerne hier wieder ein. Na, schon überfordert von der Musik. Der Mix heißt übrigens The Beautiful Beat. Das finde ich an dieser Stelle mal ganz lustig. Und ist sehr empfehlenswert, sehr abwechslungsreich. Mal was ganz Neues, was dabei als Erinnerung rausgekommen ist. Mehr Feedback. Chaosradio 110, Fighting the War, die lange drei Stunden Talk-Sendung. Erfreut sich bei euch offensichtlich größter Beliebtheit. Einerseits bekommen wir eine Menge Feedback dazu. Andererseits sind die Download-Zahlen von der Sendung doch ziemlich beeindruckend. Schon in den ersten drei Stunden ging das 5.000 Mal über den Tisch. Und das reißt auch nicht ab. Und wir haben einiges Feedback dazu bekommen. Und es beginnt mit... Ja, also wer die Sendung noch nicht gehört hat, möchte vielleicht mal reinhören. Das ist natürlich ziemlich lang. Wir hatten dann einen Anrufer, bzw. eine Anruferin, die berichtete davon, dass sie bei der Wahl in Schleswig-Holstein Bleistifte verwendet hat. Und da gab es allerlei Verwundern zunächst einmal auf unserer Seite. Aber später riefen dann immer noch mehr Leute an, die auch meinten, dass sie dort Bleistifte hatten. Und die Anruferin, die fand das halt irgendwie alles nicht so lustig, weil sie halt dachte, man könnte das einfach wieder wegradieren. Und wie ist denn das überhaupt mit der Wahlfreiheit? Na ja, erste Mail dazu von Translucent. Er schreibt, oder sie schreibt, ich weiß es gar nicht. Ah ja, Thomas, alles klar. Hallo Chaosradio, ich höre euch im Podcast halt ein paar Sendungen. Die Sache mit den Bleistiften bei der Bundestagswahl kann ich nur bestätigen. Zugegeben, ich habe nicht protestiert. Ich war doch sehr überrascht auf Nachfragen bei den Aachener Wahlhelfern, teilte man mir mit, da schon alles seine Richtigkeit hat und ich mich bei der Auszählung vom korrekten Vorgehen überzeugen könnte. Mich würde schon interessieren, was eure Recherchen ergeben. Was den Kampf angeht, niemals aufgeben. Ja, das können wir dir schon mal versprechen, dass wir das nicht tun werden. Zweiter Kommentar war dann von Wolfram, der sich dann auch zu den Bleistiften äußerte und ein interessantes PDF-Dokument hinterlassen hat. Und dieses Dokument ist eine offizielle Information des schleswig-holsteinischen Landtags. Und dort drin sind verschiedene Aspekte der Wahl besprochen. Unter anderem ist dort auch von diversen Einsprüchen die Rede. Unter anderem dieser hier. Der Einspruchsführer trägt in seiner, also ich zitiere jetzt aus diesem PDF-Dokument, der Einspruchsführer trägt in seiner Einspruchsbegründung vor, dass in seinem Wahlbezirk zur Stimmabgabe ein handelsüblicher Bleistift ausgelegt worden sei. Ich liebe dieses Juristen-Deutsche. Es bestünde nach seiner Auffassung bei der Verwendung von radierfähigen Stiften zur Kennzeichnung von Stimmzetteln die Möglichkeit der nachträglichen Manipulation. Ihm sei bekannt, dass aus diesem Grund in den rechtlichen Bestimmungen anderer Bundesländer die Pflicht zur Ausstattung der Wahlzettel mit nicht radierfähigen Schreibstiften zwingend vorgeschrieben sei. Und dann kommt dann gleich darunter das Ergebnis der Vorprüfung. Und da heißt es, der Einspruch ist unbegründet, ein Wahlfehler ist nicht erkennbar. Wahlrechtlich ist zur Landtagswahl, wie auch zur Europawahl, zur Bundestagswahl und zu allen anderen Wahlen und Abstimmungen in Schleswig-Holstein die Art der zu verwendenden Schreibstifte nicht vorgeschrieben. Es können zur Kennzeichnung des Stimmzettels demnach nicht nur Tintenstifte, Filzstifte oder Kugelschreiber, sondern auch Bleistifte benutzt werden. Die LWO, das steht wohl für Landeswahlordnung, sieht an verschiedenen Stellen Vorkehrungen vor, die sicherstellen, dass gekennzeichnete Stimmzettel nicht von Mitgliedern des Wahlvorstands oder von Dritten gefälscht, in Klammern zum Beispiel radiert, werden können. Hier ist insbesondere die gegenseitige Beaufsichtigung der einzelnen Wahlvorstandsmitglieder, das Prinzip der Öffentlichkeit bei der Wahlhandlung und bei der Ergebnisermittlung und die Verpackung, Versiegelung und Sicherstellung der Stimmzettel bis zur Übergabe der Wahlunterlagen nach Schluss der Wahlhandlung an die Gemeindewahlbehörde zu nennen. Es ist hier noch kein Fall bekannt geworden, in dem quasi vor den Augen der übrigen Wahlvorstandsmitglieder und der Öffentlichkeit ein Mitglied des Wahlvorstands bei der Auszählung der Stimmzettel nach Schluss der Stimmabgabe ein Bleistiftkreuz auf dem Stimmzettel weggradiert und durch ein Kreuz an anderer Stelle ersetzt hätte. Ihr hört schon, es ist einfach noch nie aufgetreten und das ist quasi nicht möglich, denn hier werden ja Prinzipien eingehalten und man guckt sich auch gegenseitig an und überhaupt und die Verpackung und die Versiedelung. Also ich denke, wir sind pretty safe. Gut, ich will gar nicht so viel vorlesen, lieber noch ein bisschen Feedback hier einfließen lassen. Sebastian äußert sich zum gesamten Thema der Sendung und fragt, was kann man selber machen und fragt vor allem nach technischen Möglichkeiten, was man machen kann mit Verschlüsselung. Das führt jetzt hier ein bisschen zu weit. Diese Sendung wird sowieso viel zu lang werden und ich habe mich aber schon mit ein paar Leuten unterhalten und ich denke, einer der nächsten Podcast wird sich genau mit solchen Sachen, also Anonymizer-Systeme, wie verschlüssel ich meinen gesamten Internetdatenweg und wie verschlüssel ich auch unter Umständen meine Datenwege, also die Verbindungsdaten selber, wie kann ich verschleiern, mit wem ich überhaupt kommuniziere. Das werden wir alles aufgreifen und deswegen halte ich an dieser Stelle da auch mal einen Maul, denn ich bin auch gar nicht der Experte, aber in solchen werde ich mir dann dazuhören. Dann haben wir hier noch Zottel, der fragt, ihr habt in der Sendung unter anderem Festplattenverschlüsselung angesprochen, worauf ich mal die Frage habe, ob es für Mac OS X hier gute Lösungen gibt. Das systemeigene FileVault ist meines Wissens ja nur eine 128-Bit- Verschlüsselung, welche ja leicht knackbar sein soll. Habt ihr irgendwelche Tipps für mich? Ja, gut, auch das ist sicherlich dann auch Thema dieser Verschlüsselungssendung. Allerdings kann ich dir hierzu schon mal was sagen. Erstens, 128-Bit-Verschlüsselung sagt an sich erstmal gar nichts aus, weil das hängt immer ganz davon ab, was für einen Algorithmus verwendet wird. Das ist das eigentlich Wichtige. Also diese Bitzahl sagt zwar etwas aus über eine Schlüsselsicherheit, aber immer nur, wenn man auch weiß, worüber man redet, also in welchem Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus man redet. In diesem Fall ist es der AES- Algorithmus, der bisher als noch nicht geknackt gilt und von daher ist diese AES-128-Bit-Verschlüsselung durchaus als recht sicher anzusehen. Das ist natürlich immer alles relativ, weil ihr wisst, wenn es nächstes Mal ein zwölfjähriger Inder in den nächsten Tagen eine Möglichkeit herausfindet, wie man Primzahlen mal ganz schnell zwischendurch beim Frühstück zurückrechnen kann, aus großen Zahlen, dann ist sowieso alles vorbei mit der Verschlüsselung, aber das hat bisher noch nicht passiert und deswegen gilt das alles noch als sicher. Ich habe dir auch, glaube ich, eine Mail geschrieben und da steht noch ein bisschen mehr drin, als ich jetzt hier sagen kann. Ja, so viel zum Thema Chaosradio 110 und dann habe ich noch ein bisschen allgemeines Feedback bekommen und zwar von diesem jungen Mann hier und der kommt jetzt mal kurz zur Sprache.
Hallo liebe Chaotiker, ich wollte mich an dieser Stelle mal für die Podcast vom Chaos Computer Club bedanken. Ich bin fleißiger Hörer und das, obwohl die eine oder andere Sendung meinen technischen Horizont dann doch übersteigt. Aber ein paar Dinge nehme ich doch mit, so surfe ich zum Beispiel mittlerweile anonymisiert durchs Internet. Und das eben nicht, weil ich etwas zu verstecken habe, sondern einfach, weil es da tatsächlich um die Wahrung eines Grundrechtes geht. Das ist meiner Meinung nach ein wichtiger Gedanke, der ruhig noch öfters für die breite Masse thematisiert werden sollte. Also weiter so mit dem Chaos Express und den anderen Inhalten auf eurem Feed. Ich will jetzt aber nicht nur ein Audio- Feedback hinterlassen, sondern habe auch ein Mitbringsel dabei. Ich selbst bin ja Moderator des NeuroTainment Podcasts, in dem es um Unterhaltung fürs Unterbewusstsein geht. Ein Freund von mir namens Overpop steuert da immer wieder Musik dazu bei und ich habe mich da an eine Sache erinnert, die er mir mal zugeschickt hatte. Und die vielleicht zum Chaosradio passt. Es geht nämlich um Dateinamenerweiterungen und Kraftwerk. Was er gemacht hat, ist, dass sie das Model von Kraftwerk als MP3-Datei zu nehmen, die Dateinamenerweiterung MP3 dann in Punkt-Doc umzuwandeln, das Ganze in Word als Hieroglyphen-Textdatei zu öffnen, neu abzuspeichern und dann das Ganze wieder als MP3 umzubenennen. Und wenn man das dann abspielt, klingt das sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig, aber wie ich finde, auch ganz interessant, da da irgendwo auch immer noch ganz schwach Kraftwerk zu erkennen ist. Das ist also im Grunde genommen ein Bill Gates Remix eines Kraftwerk-Songs. Naja, ihr könnt da ja mal reinhören und ich bin euch auch nicht böse, wenn ihr nicht die ganzen drei Minuten durchhört. Vielleicht kann mir ja mal einer von euch erklären, wieso sich das überhaupt so anhört, wie es sich anhört. Also weiter so mit eurer Sendung und viele Grüße von mir, Andreas vom Neurotainment Podcast.
Okay, Andreas, Nachricht ist rübergekommen. Mir schwarnte ja schon Böses, als du dein Experiment angekündigt hast und ich will es jetzt hier auch dem geneigten Hörer mal ganz kurz vorspielen, aber nicht sehr lange. Das hört sich nämlich so an. Ja, das kommt dabei raus, wenn man so einen Unfug treibt und ich weiß gar nicht, warum dich das so verwundert. Was ihr gemacht habt, ist ihr habt einfach ein Audio-Dateiformat in ein Textdokument umgewandelt. Dann habt ihr das auch noch mit Word gemacht. Das heißt, Word speichert das dann auch wieder ganz anders ab, als es eingelesen hat. Und da kann einfach nur Müll bei rauskommen. Also Word ist ja nicht gerade dafür bekannt, ich muss das hier schon mal rausziehen, das ist ja wirklich grauenhaft. Word ist ja noch nicht mal dafür bekannt, dass es seine eigenen Daten besonders konsistent abspeichert. Zumindest speichert es nicht immer nur das ab, was man sieht, sondern auch das, was man irgendwann mal geschrieben hat. Sehr schön bei juristischen Briefwechseln. Irgendwann könnte man sich auch noch mal diese Dateien genauer anschauen, da sind interessante Details drin. Aber sowas kommt da halt einfach bei raus. Es handelt sich dann einfach nicht um eine korrekt geschrieben MP3-Datei, das schreibt halt einfach nur ein Audioprogramm und das ist nun mal Word nicht. Es sei dahingestellt, ob es sich dabei auch um eine richtige Textverarbeitung handelt. Wir kommen zum zweiten Teil der Sendung und das Thema soll Mac Security sein. Beziehungsweise war es bereits, denn ich habe ein Gespräch geführt über Skype mit ein paar kompetenten Menschen, dem Angelo, dem Michael und dem Leonhard. Und darauf gekommen bin ich deshalb, weil in den letzten Tagen und Wochen über die Newsticker mal wieder so ein bisschen Lauteils über Sicherheitslücken beim Macintosh gesprochen wurde. Und ich dachte mir, unterhalte ich mich mal mit den Jungs rausgekommenes, dabei wieder ein viel zu langes Interview. Ihr wisst schon, eine halbe Stunde. Aber ich hoffe, dass euch das mal ein paar Einblicke bringt. Einerseits, was da nun tatsächlich vorgefallen ist. Andererseits auch, wie das so in der Macintosh-Szene selber bewertet wird. Da würde ich mich ganz besonders um Feedback kümmern. Ich will auch gleich vorweggeben, das Gespräch ist ein paar Tage her. Mittlerweile ist ein umfangreiches System-Update von Apple nachgeliefert worden, wo relativ viele, wenn nicht sogar alle, von diesen angesprochenen Sicherheitslücken behoben wurden. Im Einzelnen habe ich das noch nicht gecheckt. Aber das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz normal, dass sich eine Firma darum kümmert, gut zu sehen, dass es überhaupt stattfindet. Ich blende jetzt einfach mal in diese Aufzeichnung und wünsche euch viel Spaß bei dem Gespräch. Die Tonqualität ist leider so, das war so mein erstes Experiment mit Skype. Man lernt. Wichtig ist es vor allem, dass man gute Mikrofone verwendet. Das war jetzt leider nicht durchgehend der Fall. Okay, dann schalten wir einfach mal um. So, und jetzt sind wir hier im Skype-Chat unterwegs. Die CPU-Last liegt bei 100 Prozent. Mal gucken, wie sich das auswirkt. Ich begrüße jetzt gleich drei Mac-Streiter mit mir hier. Da ist zunächst einmal der Angelo Laub. Hallo, Angelo. Du bist auch schon ziemlich lange auf dem Macintosh dabei und hast letztes Jahr auch auf dem Kongress einen kleinen alarmierenden Vortrag gehalten zu möglichen Schwachstellen. Dann haben wir noch den Michael Feiri.
Hi, hallo.
Auch aus dem tiefen Süden Deutschlands dazu gestoßen. Du bist auch schon ein richtig langer Macintosh-User, oder?
Ich bin schon ewig debainger, also auch vor OSC-Zeiten.
Okay, und der dritte im Bunde ist Leo, Leonhard Becker. Hallo, Leo. Du machst das Macintosh-Blog fscklog.com, jetzt auch schon seit einiger Zeit. Für mich eine immer wieder sehr positive Ressource, weil eigentlich immer alles drin ist, was eigentlich wirklich wichtig ist und nicht sehr viel mehr. Und das Ganze dann auch mit einem etwas zurückhaltenderen Ton, als man das von so anderen Macintosh-Postillen so gewohnt ist. Ja, das ist dir dann auch gelungen, würde ich sagen. Ja, wir haben uns jetzt mal ein bisschen zusammengefunden, um mal so ein bisschen zu schwatzen, da ja in der letzten Woche das Thema Macintosh Security stärker wieder in die Medien gerutscht ist. Es gab dazu einige Veröffentlichungen, eigentlich wieder mal nur von Sicherheitsfirmen. Zusätzlich gab es auch noch einen ganz ekligen Fehler, der im OS schlummert, der sich bei Safari bemerkbar macht. Und ja, die große Meldung war wieder einmal, der erste Virus für die Macintosh-Plattform ist gefunden. Die heiligen, geschützten Zeiten sind vorbei. Angelo, du hast dich ja dazu in deinem Blog dazu geäußert, der 100. erste Virus. Kannst du da mal deine Sichtweise vielleicht kurz noch mal näher bringen?
Ja, also mich nervt es halt, dass jetzt schon zum wirklich 100. Mal immer wieder, wenn irgendwie eine kleine Lücke oder wenn irgendwie sowas ist, wird immer wieder gesagt, jetzt ist es der erste Virus für Mac OS X und der erste Wurm. Und das geht jetzt nun schon seit einigen Jahren so, dass immer wieder gesagt wird. Und beim nächsten Mal haben wir es dann schon wieder vergessen, dass es den ersten ja eh schon gab. Es ist halt einfach nicht so leicht zu sagen, was der erste war und wann es den gab. Und meistens ist es auch nie wirklich, wir haben auch noch nie wirklich einen in the wild gesehen. Das waren halt bis jetzt auch immer noch nur Proof of Concept-Würmer oder Viren in der Art. Wobei Virus natürlich auch ein falscher Begriff ist an der Stelle. Da müsste man vielleicht gleich auch noch was dazu sagen.
Ja, sag doch mal was gleich dazu. Virus, Wurm, Trojaner, ich habe sowieso den Eindruck, dass das eigentlich immer ziemlich bunt durcheinander verwendet wird.
Ja, also ich habe den Eindruck bei dieser Malware, man müsste eigentlich Malware sagen, das ist eigentlich so die Überkategorie von diesen ganzen Viren, Würmern und Trojanern. Meistens sind das ja eh immer Mischformen. So ein Viech hat ja meistens immer Aspekte von einem Wurm, das ist, wenn es andere Dateien infiziert, von einem Virus, wenn es andere Dateien infiziert, oder von einem Wurm, wenn es sich selber weiterverbreitet, also wenn es Replikationsroutinen hat, wenn es sich selber per E-Mail oder per Instant Messaging verschicken kann. Und ein Trojaner ist es, wenn die Datei sich als harmloses Pfeil tarnt und den User verführt, es anzuklicken. Und eigentlich alle Malware-Dinger, die wir jetzt in der vergangenen Zeit gesehen hatten, waren eigentlich Mischformen, waren also meistens Trojaner mit Replikationsroutinen, also so eine Mischung aus Wurm und Trojaner eigentlich.
Wer war denn jetzt der Erste, der jetzt den neuen Rummel ausgelöst hat?
Ja, der Erste, das war dieser Leap A, so wurde der von Symantec. Als erste Anti-Viren-Firma haben die den analysiert, nachdem der allerdings auch schon in Foren analysiert wurde. Der war folgendermaßen, der wurde in einem Forum gepostet, das war ein Target-Set-File, angeblich Bilder von dem neuen Leopard, von der zukünftigen Mac OS X.
Das wirkt ja auf Macintosh User wie Porn auf alle anderen.
Ja genau, die Windows-Würmer sind immer irgendwie mit nackten Mädchen und die Mac-Würmer sind dann irgendwie mit Screenshots von nicht-releaseden Softwareversionen.
Das macht sie heiß.
Ja genau, das ist die Mac-Community.
Okay, und dann haben sie alle drauf geklickt und was ist dann passiert?
Und dieses Target-Set enthielt allerdings Shell-Skripte, bzw. diese JPEGs waren in Wirklichkeit Shell-Skripte, die aussahen wie JPEGs. Hatten das richtige Icon, hatten die richtige Datei-Endung und per Doppelklick hat sich aber kein Bild gezeigt, sondern wurde Schabernack auf dem System getrieben. Es wurde ein Input-Manager-Bundle installiert, was sich an iChat dran gehängt hat und hat sich per iChat an andere Instant-Message-Kontakte verschickt.
Lass uns das in einzelne Schritte aufbrechen. Zunächst einmal, man befindet sich irgendwo und dann hier, so hier, geiler Mac-Porn-Click-Now. Und dann kommt dieses TGZ. Packt sich das dann schon automatisch aus?
Das Interessante ist, wenn man das mit Safari runterlädt, dann packt sich das schon automatisch in der Standardeinstellung.
Und die Standardeinstellung ist dieses kleine Fleck mit pack einfach alles aus, was prima ist. Und da gehören TGZs und SIPs einfach schon mal dazu.
Genau. Aber durch dieses Auspacken von diesem TGZ geschieht noch nichts. Man muss schon wirklich noch auf diese JPEG-Bilder draufklicken. Ich habe dieses Stück auch nicht selber gesehen. Sobald diese Nachricht bekannt wurde, war es einfach nicht mehr zu bekommen. Dieses Programm, das Original-Pfeil, war in dem Forum nicht mehr gelöscht und es war nicht mehr zu bekommen. Ich hätte ihn gerne mal selber auch analysiert.
Und hat jemand anderes von euch den gesehen? Also hat man das Ding in der Hand gehabt?
Das letzte, was mir noch zu Ohren gekommen ist, aber ich weiß auch nicht, wie da der endgültige Stand ist, ist das vor allem, der sich zwar in iChat einklingt, aber lediglich übers lokale Netzwerk verbreitet, also über die Bonjour-Geschichte. Insofern, dass sowieso von der Reichweite eigentlich ziemlich limitiert gewesen sein müsste. Aber ich habe es selber auch nicht gesehen.
Es war auch diese beiden Komponenten, die Verbreitung über iChat und auch das Verpacken als executable, war ja auch nichts Neues in dem Sinn. Von daher konnte man sich ja denken, wie es funktioniert. Man brauchte eigentlich das Teil auch nicht unbedingt haben.
Ja, genau. Und das Interessante ist eigentlich, also alle diese Techniken, die sind nicht neu. Das wurde alles auch schon in Proof of Concepts vorher gezeigt, dass man halt irgendwie executables als harmlose Dokumente verpacken kann, sei es PDF, MP3 oder JPEGs. Das haben wir alles schon gesehen.
Das macht sogar Apple selbst. Es ist glaube ich nicht so bekannt, ob das die Readme von iLife sind oder waren zumindest mal genau solche getarnten Programme. Das sind PDF-Dokumente, die werden doppel geklickt. Und dann öffnet sich nicht ein PDF-Dokument, sondern ein Programm, das schaut nach, in welcher Sprache ihr es gerade aktiviert und startet dann das entsprechende PDF-Dokument mit Preview-App. Also selbst Apple genutzt solche Trojanofunktionen eigentlich.
Ja, it's a Feature, not a Bug. Das kennen wir ja nun schon aus der Windows-Welt. Ja, okay, Proof of Concept. Ich meine, es gibt jetzt verschiedene Sachen, die ich da interessant finde. Das Erste, das hast du ja schon angesprochen, ist diese Installation über, also gehen wir mal davon aus, das Programm wird angeklickt. Dass irgendwie sowas angeklickt wird, wissen wir alle, das wird einfach passieren. Und wenn es nicht sogar schon, dann der Browser eben auch automatisch macht, wie wir das ja bei dem anderen Safari-Bug dann auch gesehen haben. Da kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf. Aber wie, welche Möglichkeiten hat jetzt die Software unter Meco S10, sich in andere Programme hineinzuverpflanzen? Weil das ist ja das, was dieses Proof of Concept-Ding auch gemacht hat.
Ja, Meco S10 ist da sehr offen und bietet irgendwie zwei Mechanismen, die es auch Malware und natürlich auch normalen Programmen sehr einfach machen, Code in andere Programme reinzuladen, sei es nun zur Laufzeit, während Programme schon laufen, über die Mach-Injection, oder halt einfach standardmäßig in alle, beim Start, in alle Programme, in alle Coco-Programme, die geöffnet werden, werden dann diese Input-Manager-Bundles einfach dazu geladen und ausgeführt. Das heißt, sobald ich irgendwie einen Input-Manager-Bundle einfach, das ist einfach so ein Fall, das lege ich in meinem Home-Verzeichnis, in einem bestimmten Ordner, das wird dann automatisch von allen Programmen geöffnet, beim Start.
Ja, so, also für den Unbedarften klingt das natürlich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen dramatisch. Also das ist natürlich ein echtes Feature, weil man damit natürlich leicht, also das ist im Prinzip ja auch die empfohlene Methode, wie Plug-Ins sich generell installieren. Das gibt es ja jetzt nicht nur so als Input-Manager, sondern eigentlich auch in zahlreichen Plug-In-Interfaces.
Ja, genau, das kann man halt, kann man halt nutzen, wenn man Plug-Ins zum Beispiel für CoCo-Programme schreiben möchte, wie zum Beispiel für iChat, die keine Plug-In-Schnittstelle haben.
Ah ja, das heißt, damit kommt man sozusagen überall rein.
Ganz genau.
Aber dem Benutzer wird es halt zu keinem Zeitpunkt signalisiert, nach dem Motto hier ist jetzt was neu und willst du wirklich, dass das in diesem Programm jetzt auch aktiv wird? Sowas gibt es nicht.
Ja genau, das ist halt, der User merkt halt nichts davon. Und da könnte man halt wirklich überlegen, ob es da nicht vielleicht besser wäre, wenn so ein neues Input-Manager-Bundle installiert wird, den User vielleicht irgendwie darauf aufmerksam zu machen, so ähnlich wie bei den Widgets, bei den Dashboard-Widgets, da werde ich ja auch darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass irgendwie ein neues Widget jetzt irgendwie aktiviert wird oder so, dass der User dann vielleicht darauf aufmerksam gemacht wird und dass er dann vielleicht noch einschreiten kann. Das wäre vielleicht eine nette Sache.
Weil es ist ja eigentlich auch so ein Ding. Ich meine, wenn man überlegt, welche Strategien vielleicht überhaupt angemessen wären, um die Konsistenz des Systems sicherzustellen, würde mir als erstes einfallen so, das Betriebssystem muss feststellen, wenn ein Programm modifiziert wurde. Und wenn man sich so kurz einfach so reinschleichen kann, dann ist das ja fast nicht mehr möglich.
Also bei Inputmanager könnte man ja noch irgendwie so eine Warnung machen, ja. Aber wenn man jetzt nur die andere Methode benutzt, nämlich Mach-Injection, dann funktioniert das leider nicht so einfach, würde ich mir vorstellen. Also da ist es halt nicht so, dass man das irgendwie detektieren kann. Ich kann halt einfach in eine bereits laufende Applikation Code reinindizieren. Und den dann ausführen. Das kann ich einfach so machen. Das ist eine Funktion des Betriebssystems. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass man die einfach so abschalten kann.
Das ist ja interessant. Und warum gibt es diese Funktion?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Weiß vielleicht einer von den anderen Herden.
Also ich habe mal nachgeschaut, diese ganzen Mac-Injection-Geschichten, die wurden ja entdeckt von Johnson Wrench. Genau richtig. Und er hatte glaube ich irgendwas dazugeschrieben, dass das schlicht ein Feature war, was es eben schon ewig gab bei Next auch schon, in Next-Step, und da kommt es wohl irgendwie her, oder wie auch immer. Aber eine wirkliche Begründung, warum das da jetzt drin ist, gab es da nicht.
Ja, ich vermute, dass es irgendwie was mit Interprocess Communication von dem Machkernel zu tun hat. Dass die IPC intern irgendwie so läuft oder so. Das ist halt so eine Vermutung von mir, kann ich jetzt aber nicht von keiner Seite bestätigt. Ich nehme mal an, dass es irgendwas Integrales ist, was man nicht einfach so abschalten kann. Wenn ich das abschalte, würden wahrscheinlich die Hälfte aller Programme nicht mehr laufen. Ich würde es nicht direkt so nutzen.
Plugins sozusagen auf breiter Ebene. Ja, stellt man sich natürlich schon die Frage, ob an der Stelle beim Design über Sicherheit überhaupt in irgendeiner Form nachgedacht wurde.
Wobei man natürlich sagen muss, dass sowas unter Windows auch möglich ist. Da gab es vor einiger Zeit in der Datenschleuder auch ein Artikel darüber. Das funktioniert unter Windows alles ein bisschen anders, natürlich klar, aber letztendlich kann ich da das Gleiche auch unter Windows machen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, dass man unter Windows so einiges machen kann, das ist ja nun bekannt. Jetzt gilt aber, der Macintosh auch so ein bisschen kolportiert von der Szene, immer so ein bisschen als der Heilige Gral, so nach dem Motto Viren. Wie schreibt man das so? Ja, kennen wir nicht. Was natürlich insofern auch ein bisschen ein Mythos ist, weil erstmal gab es früher sehr wohl Viren auf dem Mac, also unter Mac OS 9 jetzt noch, also wir reden ja jetzt eigentlich über Mac OS 10, aber wenn man jetzt mal so Macintosh als Plattform sieht, gab es das sehr wohl. Es war kein wirklich großes Problem, aber auch damals gab es schon so haarsträubende Methoden, die einfach nur zu wenig genutzt wurden. Es war zum Beispiel möglich, einen Codeblock ausführen zu lassen, der auf einer Diskette schlummert und zwar nur indem man ihn auf dieser Diskette abspeichert und die Diskette einlegt, weil sie es dann als Window-Control-Resource angemeldet hat und dann hat das OS das einfach mal so eingelesen, so wie es ja auch von Festplatten Treiber mit reingeladen hat. Solche Hooks gab es ja dabei Mac OS 9. Nun hat sich mit Mac OS 10 natürlich alles gewandelt und bisher wurde halt noch nichts gesehen, genauso wie es ja auch eigentlich für Linux und BSD auch so etwas nicht gibt. Aber das hat natürlich auch viel damit zu tun, dass die Plattform sich immer sehr, auf der einen Seite gab es einen sehr schnellen Entwicklungsprozess, dann hat natürlich der Mac die niedrigere Verbreitung. Aber jetzt kommen wir glaube ich so langsam an so einen Punkt, wo Mac OS 10.3 und 10.4 große Verbreitung hat und die Plattform ist auch bekannt. Und was noch dazu kommt, jetzt mit den Intel Prozessoren, kommt natürlich auf einmal die große Ressource der erfahrenen Intel Assembler Programmierer dazu, die sich sicherlich das System jetzt nochmal ganz anders anschauen werden. Und dann ist die Frage, wie gut Apple an der Stelle aufgestellt ist.
Also vielleicht grundsätzlich zu dieser Geschichte mit Sicherheitslücken, über die Infektionen gemacht werden können. Ich sehe das gar nicht so kritisch heutzutage mehr. Die allermeisten Sachen, die heute passieren, sind tatsächlich solche drojane Geschichten. Sprich per E-Mail bekommt man irgendwelche Sachen oder man lässt sich irgendwas runter. Und dazu muss es ja keine Sicherheitslücken geben. Sicherheitslücken sind auf der Ebene einfach mal ganz außen vor. Diese ganzen Ausführungsgeschichten braucht man gar nicht. Man verlässt sich darauf, dass der User das schon irgendwann mal anklicken will. Diese Sachen hat es immer gegeben, wird es auch immer geben.
Ja gut, aber trotzdem will man natürlich davor auch gefeit sein. Machen wir uns nichts vor. Diese Problematik wird weiter entstehen. Ich würde ja auch widersprechen insofern, als das natürlich auch über den Internet Explorer sehr viel Code eingefangen wird, der eben ganz konkret Schwachstellen auch im Internet Explorer ausnutzt. Über JavaScript hebelt sich der Code einfach in das ausgeführte Programm auf dem Rechner rein und von dort marschiert er eben weiter.
Wenn solche Bugs dann doch noch mal auftauchen, und das tun sie immer, denn nichts ist ja im Grunde komplett bugfrei, sowas wird es nach wie vor geben, dann kassiert sowas auch ziemlich schnell. Da sind ja in der Regel diese Botnetzbetreiber ziemlich aktiv, denn da werden Webseiten präpariert, um dann Leute zu infizieren mit solchen Sachen. Das sind dann in der Regel nicht Würmer, die die selbst verbreiten, sondern das wird dann richtig von Webseitenbetreibern deployed, in großem Stil teilweise. Aber es ist einfach in der großen Masse, zumindest so wie ich es sehe, einfach nicht mehr nötig, dass man sich da den Stress macht und eine große Lücke exploite. Gerade auch die letzten beiden Geschichten für den Mac hier, dieses Bild, der hat da nicht wirklich eine Lücke ausgenutzt, um da Leute zu infizieren. Er hat einfach nur das Ding hingestellt, das war ein Programm mit einem Icon von einem JPEG oder wie auch immer, das dann im Detail ausgesehen ist. Und es hat schon gereicht. Und ich bin mir sicher, hätte dieser Trojaner dann noch nach einem Passwort gefragt, die meisten Leute hätten auch ihr Passwort da schön brav eingegeben, nach dem Motto, ja, der Computer hat es wissen wollen. Diese ganze Sicherheitsleben-Gestichte, das ist zwar alles Spaß, ich bin interessant, aber so in der breiten Masse, ja, mein Gott, die Trojaner sind in der Praxis viel blöder, weil sie viel primitiver sind, aber offensichtlich viel mehr Impact haben können.
Ja, ich finde allerdings, dass Apple da in diesem Bereich der Disguised Applications trotzdem noch Handlungsbedarf hat. Also ich sehe das schon als Sicherheitslücke an, dass es einen JPEG geben kann, dem ich es nicht ansehe, dass es in Wirklichkeit nicht executable ist.
Na ja, Ansehen über die Information sieht man es ja.
Ja, aber du kommst ja gar nicht so weit. Ich meine, das müssen wir nochmal erwähnen, was da herausgefunden ist. Das hat dieser Michael Lehn herausgefunden. Also man klickt etwas an, was erstmal aussieht wie ein ZIP-File.
Michael Lehn hat eine Lücke im Safari gefunden, da ist über den Meta-Refresh das einfach selber ausgeführt. Da muss ich gar nichts mehr anklicken. Da bin ich auf irgendeiner Seite und schwupps.
Der benutzt noch den Meta-Refresh. Das ist doch nur das ZIP-File. Das ZIP-File wird automatisch ausgepackt.
Und gestartet auch.
Genau, und zwar wird es deshalb gestartet, weil Safari packt das ZIP-File aus und schaut dann auch noch rein. Das finde ich ja so hart. Ich meine, wenn er mir das ZIP-File auspacken würde, da kann man doch drüber reden. Weil dann ist es ausgepackt. Das stört mich zwar auch, einfach vom Handling her, finde ich das einfach mal beknackt. Aber gut, dann ist es halt ausgepackt und dann liegt das wie ein ausgebreiteter Ordner vor mir. Nur, was es dann noch macht, ist, dass es dann auch noch die Dateien da drin anschaut und sieht, oh, die sieht ja super aus. Da ist ja nur ein MOF drin und MOF ist ja super, weil das ist ja QuickTime, das ist ja alles prima. Und dann sagt er dem Betriebssystem, hier bitte nimm dieses Movie und öffne es. Wobei er sich dann ja selber gar nicht mehr darum kümmert, das Programm auszuwählen.
Das war im Detail ein bisschen anders. Und zwar, das war gar kein Target-Set, er hat da nichts ausgepackt, sondern dieses Target-Set war in Wahrheit schon das Held des Shell-Skripts. Und das wurde dann schon gestartet. Es wurde nicht mal etwas entpackt. Bei dem Versuch, das zu entpacken, also quasi beim Starten von diesem Target-Set-File, ist dann statt dem Entpacken dieses Skript ausgeführt worden.
Okay, aber...
Also es hat da schon angesetzt.
Okay, aber dann war es halt ein Shell-Skript und er war sich einfach nicht dessen bewusst. Also an der Stelle wurde der Standard-Launch-Mechanismus von dem OS X, also dem, der sozusagen auch aktiviert wird, wenn man irgendwas doppelklickt, wurde einfach ungefragt aktiviert. Genau.
Das war ganz hilfreich.
Genau, weil kann ja auch Gutes bedeuten. Aber so geht es halt einfach nicht, weil hätte das Ding jetzt nicht Hello World ausgegeben, sondern einfach mal RM minus RF gemacht, das Geschrei wäre groß gewesen. Und zwar sehr gut.
Dieser Bug ist peinlich ohne Ende. Da gibt es gar keine Diskussionen.
Das ist wirklich schlimm. Ich meine, ich frage mich halt auch ernsthaft, wie Apple aufgestellt ist. Auf dem Kongress sind ja auch noch ein paar andere Sachen rumgegangen. Das ist auch nicht unbedingt alles veröffentlicht worden, soweit ich das bisher weiß. Wovon ich Wind bekommen habe, das müsste sich sicherlich auch noch mal einer anschauen. Beziehungsweise es gibt definitiv Leute, die sich das schon mal angeschaut haben, ist eine Schwäche in diesem Software-Update-Mechanismus. Wenn ihr euch erinnert, vor zwei Jahren wurde schon mal moniert, dass da keine Authentifizierung drin ist. Das haben sie dann mal eben ganz schnell nachgeschoben in einem Software-Update. Und seitdem stellt zumindest der Computer sicher, dass er sich auch mit Apple unterhält, wenn er da ein Software-Update runterlädt. Bloß offensichtlich ist es so, dass dieser Update-Vorgang auch abgefangen werden kann. Das heißt, wenn ein Tool man-in-the-middle-attack-mäßig sich einfach dazwischenschaltet und lauscht, dann wartet es einfach diese Authentifizierung ab. Und danach wird nämlich der Download von der eigentlichen Datei noch mal ganz normal über HTTP gemacht. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass man einfach was Beliebiges da übertragen kann. Und dann wird es auch gleich ins Betriebssystem installiert. Also, nicht nur. Doppelklick ist da gar keine Option. So, dann gab es noch diesen komischen Bluetooth-Wurm, aber das war doch, glaube ich, wirklich nur ein Fake, oder?
Also das war irgendwie nicht wirklich ernst zu nehmen.
Hat ihn jemand gehabt?
Nee, der wurde auch, glaube ich, offiziell als Proof-of-Concept. Der sollte nur zum Wachrütteln sein.
Und außerdem war die Sicherheitslücke ja auch schon längst gefixt, glaube ich.
Ja, eben. Die ist ja vom Mai 2005 oder so gewesen. Das war ja geschehen alles schon.
Aber es hat sich gleich so eine Hektik, so eine allgemeine, wieder breit gemacht. Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Leute, die warten gerade zu einer darauf, dass es jetzt irgendwie losgeht mit der Security-Krise auf dem Mac.
Ja, das sind immer so Schübe. Ich glaube, das ist das auch, was beim letzten Mal schon so gewesen ist, vor einem Jahr ungefähr, wo es diesen Schub gegeben hat. Da war dann, was gab es da? Den MP3-Concept gab es dann damals, der seinen ausführbaren Code im ID.3-Tag drin hatte. Dann gab es diesen Opener damals, was im Prinzip nur ein Bundle Shells-Kipps war, das als Rootkit verteilt wurde. Und diesmal wieder drei Sachen auf einmal. Das war dieser Umpa und dann diese MP3-Quatsch, diese Bluetooth-Geschichte. Und jetzt nochmal dieser Safari-Bug. Das sind, man könnte fast meinen, immer wieder so Phasen, in denen sich Leute gegenseitig aufschaukeln. Nach dem Motto, ich zeige jetzt mal, dass es geht. Mir ist das jetzt zu viel, dass immer überall behauptet wird, der Mac wäre so sicher, obwohl er eigentlich nur ein normales Betriebssystem ist, wie alle anderen auch. Und dann kommen solche Sachen über.
Ja, normales Betriebssystem, wie alle anderen auch. Na ja gut, es ist eine Illusion zu glauben, dass Unix jetzt per se Sicherheit verspricht. Das ist einfach nicht so. Das ist Quatsch. Das trägt auch eine ganze Menge Urschleim noch mit sich rum und ist sicherlich an vielen Stellen angreifbar. Microsoft hat in den letzten zwei Jahren den Security-Markt nahezu leer gekauft. Das war ganz deutlich zu hören von vielen Seiten. Die haben dermaßen viel Geld in Security-Experten investiert. Ich glaube, fast jeder Security-Experte auf diesem Planeten hat jetzt mindestens einen Sechs-Monate-Rekord bei Microsoft. Das Ergebnis ist, dass sie wohl, wenn man den Insiderberichten ein bisschen trauen darf, tatsächlich wirklich umfassende Maßnahmen eingeleitet haben, um ihr System von ganz vielen Stellen her abzusichern. Ob das alles Erfolg haben wird, das muss man natürlich jetzt auch noch mal sehen. Aber immerhin gibt es diesen Trend. Und das ist bei Apple derzeit einfach noch nicht spürbar.
Also zumindest nach außen hin nicht. Ich denke, die Strategie, die Apple verfolgt, ist einfach, das möglichst tot zu schweigen. Denn sobald Apple rausgeht und sagt, wir machen Security technisch das und das und das und das, dann ruft man sofort die Leute auf den Plan, die dann auch das und das und das wieder aushebeln. Das ist ganz normal, der Lauf der Dinge.
Ja, aber das ist Security bei Obscurity. Das funktioniert nicht, das können Sie vergessen.
Na ja, es ist Security durch nicht so viel Gestreit rum machen. Also wenn ich mich hinstelle und sage, mein System ist hier Unbreakable Mac OS X, dann habe ich sofort alles auf den Plan und jeder macht sich einen Spaß daraus, da reinzugehen. Und wir wissen ja immer, es ist klar, dass immer irgendwo Bugs sind. Es gibt kein bugfreies System, auch wenn man noch so viel Geld reinstopft.
Ja gut, aber wir reden ja hier über zahlreiche Proof of Concepts und Proof of Concept heißt, im Prinzip geht das, man müsste es nur machen. Und dagegen hat ja irgendwie noch keiner was gesagt. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo einer mal losgeht und dann auch alle zusammensammelt und aus diesen ganzen Proof of Concepts die Concepts auch einfach mal durchimplementiert, dann wird es einfach funktionieren. Und an der Stelle muss man sich dann fragen, was tut denn das Betriebssystem bitte an dieser Stelle, um das auch wirklich zu verhindern? Also wo ist jetzt, ja, wo ist die Sicherheit? Wie kann es sein, dass ein beliebiges Programm in ein beliebiges anderes Programm zur Laufzeit Code injizieren und ausführen kann? Wie kann es sein, dass ich mich an irgendeine Stelle in einem Home-Direktor schreibe und ich bin automatisch in jedem gestartetem Programm? Also meine, früher war ja Infizieren von einem Programm echt noch viel schwieriger.
Im Grunde kann man nichts dagegen tun, dass der User Programme starten kann und dass die Programme, die der User startet, dann auch Schreibrechte auf des Home-Verzeichniss haben.
Ja gut, das ist sicherlich so.
Also was man machen kann, was ich auch sehr sinnvoll fände, wäre zum Beispiel mal Bereiche einzuführen, in denen einfach keine Programme ausgeführt werden können. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich auf dem Desktop Dateien rumliegen habe, ich möchte nicht, dass Dateien, die auf dem Desktop liegen, ausgeführt werden können.
Es dürfen nur Programme ausgeführt werden, wenn sie in Slash-Applications liegen.
Das wäre zum Beispiel mal mit relativ wenig Aufwand machbar und wäre ein sehr guter Schritt. Ganz einfach.
So einen sicheren Bereich schaffen. Was hast du noch für Vorschläge, Angelo? Hast du denn mal Rückmeldungen bekommen von Apple nach dem Vortrag?
Also ich habe keine offizielle Rückmeldung auf den Vortrag bekommen. Allerdings die Bug-Reports. Alles, was mir damals auch gefallen ist, habe ich an Apple weitergeleitet, in die Security-Abteilung. Da kamen die Standard-Antworten zurück. Vielen Dank für Ihren Bug-Report. Wir haben das an die Engineering-Section weitergeleitet und die wird sich jetzt darum kümmern. Bei einigen ist das bis heute nicht gefixt worden. Diese Geschichte, dass sich Applications als harmlose Dateien tarnen kann, das habe ich vor gut anderthalb Jahren schon bei Apple reportet und war wahrscheinlich auch nicht der Erste, der das gemacht hat. Aber da hat Apple bis heute noch keinen Deut unternommen. Ich glaube, man muss da irgendwas tun, auch wenn es jetzt irgendwie ist, dass die ausübbaren Dateien ein Häkchen bekommen oder irgendwas. Ich meine, bei Aliases, bei Verknüpfungen, schaffen sie das ja auch, dass sie irgendwie so ein Häkchen bekommen. Das könnte ich zum Beispiel bei ausübbaren Dateien auch machen.
Also, dass es zumindest erstmal sicher erkennbar ist, dass es sich jetzt hierbei um ein Programm handelt und nicht zum Beispiel um einen PDF.
Ganz genau. Das würde halt schon mal unglaublich helfen. Weil dann sehe ich, da muss ich nicht erst irgendwie Apple-E drücken und irgendwie gucken, ist das jetzt irgendwie eine Application oder nicht. Das würde halt wirklich helfen. Da könnte man auch den normalen User, den täglichen Gebrauch eben darauf trainieren, eben darauf zu achten. Oder eine andere Möglichkeit wäre halt zum Beispiel, es gibt nur bestimmte Dateiendungen, die ausgeführt werden dürfen, zum Beispiel. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich schwierig, das wirklich durchzusetzen.
Und Michael, hast du noch ein paar Wünsche? Wünsche? Also gibt es so Bereiche, wo du es so richtig krachen siehst?
Ja, nein, eigentlich, ja, ich denke, es ist etwas, mit dem man leben muss. Ganz einfach, man muss die Leute trainieren, dass sie nicht auf alles will, doppelklicken, was ihnen in die Finger gerät. Denn wenn mal ein Programm läuft, egal, ob es My Injections gibt oder nicht, kann das Programm alles tun, was der User kann, sprich, auch ein iChat bedienen oder was auch immer, E-Mails verschicken, da brauche ich gar keine My Injections zu, obwohl es natürlich My Injections extrem vereinfachen. Also im Prinzip, ja, Usertraining ist dem User möglichst einfach machen, Programme zu erkennen oder vielleicht Vorkehrungen treffen, dass man nicht so, ja, das erste beste runtergeladene File gleich doppelt klippt.
Also ich könnte mir natürlich schon, ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass man in dem Betriebssystem auch schon ein bisschen mehr Abstraktion macht. Also warum zum Beispiel sollte es jedem Programm automatisch erlaubt sein, bei mir irgendwas zu beschreiben? Warum kann ich nicht ein Programm starten und dieses Programm, wenn ich sowas habe wie Preview, ja, was mir einfach ein PDF anzeigt, dann sehe ich nicht ein, dass es dafür irgendetwas schreiben muss. Und wenn ich jetzt einfach irgendein Programm runter lade und dieses Programm darf einfach erstmal von vornherein nichts schreiben und wenn es schreiben will, dann geht genauso der Dialog auf, der fragt, also so, wenn ich hier Little Snitch installiere, dann sagt er mir ja auch hier, der will nach Hause telefonieren, willst du das jetzt erlauben? So ja, einmal, aber dann nie wieder und so weiter. Und warum kommt nicht das Betriebssystem genauso hoch und sagt, also dieses Programm, das will jetzt mal ein bisschen schreiben? Vielleicht zumindest ein paar Ausnahmen, was weiß ich, so mit Voreinstellungen schreiben. Da gibt es ja auch alles definierte Orte dafür. Und das könnte schon ein bisschen mehr Transparenz bringen in das System. Da könnte man auf jeden Fall Sachen verhindern.
Ja, sowas gibt es ja. Und zwar die Java-Leute haben sowas ja probiert oder probieren es immer noch und sind damit aber ziemlich auf die Nase gefallen, weil die Leute eben gesagt haben, ich kriege dauernd ganz böse Anmeldungen, dass hier möglicherweise schädliche Programme ausgeführt werden, ob ich mir sicher sei, dass ich das wirklich tun will. Und wenn ich das dreifelmal bekommen habe, dann machen es die Leute gar nicht mehr, weil sie sich nicht trauen oder sich beschweren sich bei mir, was ich denn da für ein schreckliches Ding bei ihnen installiert habe oder was ich da angeroten habe.
Der Benutzer, das zerbrechliche Wesen, ist an der Stelle natürlich auf jeden Fall auch.
Oder im ganz extremen Fall bekomme ich dann diese Trusted Computing Schiene, dass eben nur noch Code ausgeführt wird, der ein Signaturtest besteht.
Ja, ich denke, die Diskussion könnten wir jetzt noch lange führen, aber jetzt haben wir auch die halbe Stunde voll. Länger sollten wir das jetzt hier auch, glaube ich, nicht machen. Ich bedanke mich auf jeden Fall erst mal bei der Runde, dass ihr alle dabei wart. Und ich denke, wir halten einfach alle mal die Augen offen und schauen auch mal, was an Feedback dazu reinkommt, und dann können wir die Diskussion ja zu gegebener Zeit nochmal fortsetzen. So, das war's. Eine halbe Stunde Macintosh-Gekwatsche. Ich hoffe, da war was für euch dabei. Wenn dem so ist, dann schreibt uns oder plappert uns auf den Anrufbeantworter unter 018 01 99 33 22 99 55. Da wartet die Maschine. Oder wie es der Andreas gemacht hat von dem Neurotainment-Podcast, nehmt einfach was auf. Das ist auch immer sehr schön, aber auch eine normale E-Mail tut's. Und ich mach jetzt hier erstmal Schluss. Das ist ein ziemlicher Patchwork-Podcast gewesen. Ihr habt auch sicherlich mitbekommen, in dem Skype-Gespräch gab es so einige Klappergeräusche, Festplatten, die sich da eingemischt haben. Ich hab so versucht, so gut ich eben konnte, damit Frequenzfiltern auch ein bisschen beizukommen. Ist ein bisschen weird, aber das wird bestimmt bald besser. So, genug gequatscht. Der nächste Podcast kommt bestimmt. Und ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr auch das nächste Mal wieder zuhört. Insofern sag ich Tschüss und bis bald.